willkommen zur heutigen sitzung in der
wir uns mit dem begriff der verzweiflung
weise tätig befassen werden
ein banker der stark theologisch
orientiert ist aber nichtsdestotrotz ist
er der denker der verzweiflung wie man
sich also mit der verzweiflung befassen
möchte theoretisch dann kommt die kicker
nicht vorbei und wie man jetzt auch in
den letzten sitzungen möchte ich noch
mal so einen kurzen überblick über das
seminar geben dass sie sehen auch die
anderen zuschauer im zu schauen wo wir
gerade stehen und die letzten sitzung
hatten behandelt und zwar nannte theorie
und muss bauen ich komme in der heutigen
sitzung auch noch mal kurz rückblick auf
die zu sprechen
in der heutigen sitzung geht es wie sie
bereits gehört haben um kickers begriff
der verzweiflung wir wollen wir schauen
ob verzweiflung eine emotion ist so wie
wir sie bisher verstanden haben
in der nächsten sitzung die das
wiederbetätigung und zwar diesmal über
die emotionen der angst und auch noch
bei heiliger und seiner theorie der
angst heiliger spricht davon dass angst
eine stimmung sei das ist ein gestimmt
zu sein des menschen sein muss man
schauen und wir stimmung auch 1
emotionen verstehen können so wie wir
auch kunsttheorie des mitleids
versprachen passion die deutsche
besetzung war effekt nach rechts links
dieser sitzung ein
als emotionen verstehen könnten jugend
hat das geklappt in mancher hinsicht wie
gesagt effekte sind nicht dasselbe wie
emotionen aber in der eu mission
technologie können wir bestimmte formen
von effekt als emotionen verstehen
dann geht es weiter mit neid und
eifersucht platon aristoteles geht man
die artikel dann kommen noch mal wasser
zurück und zwar diesmal auf den hass und
zwar in seinem philosophischen hauptwerk
das sein und das nichts da ein seiten
sehr interessant zum thema
und vielleicht werden auch andere
theorien eingehen übrigen hass und so
weiter das ist ja gerade sehr zentral
jetzt haben wir da noch zum schluss die
liebe an alle von augustinus und arendt
und wir haben noch ein dicker mit dem
namen berlin frankfurt der lebt noch und
bier hat auch was interessantes zum
thema liebe gesagt das ist der plan des
seminars schon jetzt gehen wir noch mal
zurück auf die letztes bisschen sie
zahlten und zur seite aus einer
existenzialisten pfeife im mund und was
gibts des auftritts zu sagen
in diesem roman der ekel der als das
existenz philosophische hauptwerk von
saab gilt der überhaupt die existenz
vieler sich auch sehr treffend
verkörpert da schilderte
phänomenologische die erfahrung des
ekels anhand dieses protagonisten des
romans und zwar sieht dieser boden ist
die wurzel eines kastanienbaum im park
als sie an sich nichts ungewöhnliches
ist doch ist diese wurzel des
kastanienbaum der anlass für ein
existenzialistisches erleben in dem auch
der ekel hervor tritt existenz ist jetzt
für diesen protagonisten und vater nicht
meine abstrakte kategorien
ich darf daran erinnern dass kant die
existenz als etwas normales bestimmt
hatte was kein reales prädikat sein
so ist es jetzt patrick gerade nicht
sondern die existenz tritt mit einem mal
etwas hervor was ich konkret enthüllt
und als obszön und ekelerregend sogar
erscheint er spricht auch von schimmel
der da irgendwie sich mit assoziiert es
ist etwas sehr konkretes und auch als
abstoßend ist zunächst jedenfalls
wir haben dann gesagt ich hatte diese
betrieben dass der ekel nur ein moment
innerhalb eines großen erkenntnis
prozesses des protagonisten über die
existenz darstellt
an dessen ende eben nicht mehr der ecke
bleibt sondern ihr die erkenntnis der
absurdität die existenz und zwar eben
als etwas durch und durch kontingentes
wird völlig zufällig ist eben gerade
nichts mit notwendigkeit zu tun hat ich
denke ich so sagen die
existenzialistische grundhaltung
spiegelt und der auch der ekel irgendwie
überwunden ist oder aufgehoben
also ekel spielt eigentlich gar nicht so
eine große rolle im gesamten roman aber
es gibt eben diese passagen so das war
das zur seite und jetzt noch kurz zumal
nußbaum die eben einen ganz anderen
zugang zu ekeln philosophisch wählt sie
argumentiert dass die regeln nicht nur
als ein körperliches phänomen verstanden
werden kann sondern dass er auch einen
komplexen gehalt hat
der in die erkenntnis besteht etwas
schädliches in sich aufzunehmen
also das ist
das ist dieser punkt komplexe emotion
der ekel kann auch als reaktion auf
etwas fremdes verstanden werden was
nicht als wir da ist und nussbaum
argumentiert dass die insel als emotion
noch stärker und aggressiver ist als
bloße abneigung oder angst das ist so
sollen das was jetzt mein nußbaum
einschaltet ist hinzu kommt noch dass
das objekt des ekels den meisten fällen
sozial konstruiert ist also es ist
nichts was irgendwie jetzt angeboren ist
zeit dass etwas was variabel ist und
darin zeigt sich auch die soziale
konstruktion des ekels genau es zeigt
sich eben auch dass emotionen durch ihre
kognitive dimension angefallen sind
sie behalten sie haben eine dynamik in
sich die wir bei stimmung und effekten
so nicht finden das ist mir jetzt noch
mal bei dieser analyse des ekels
gekommen
stimmungen sind ziemlich gleichgerichtet
und emotionen scheint sich verschiedene
in strömen und kann man schon sagen
verschiedene tendenzen die auch
gegeneinander gerichtet sind
gleichermaßen aufhalten zu können das
ist also etwas was emotionen zusätzlich
aussagen und können sagen ihre
komplexität ihre innere gespanntheit die
es bei der stimmung so meines erachtens
nicht gibt denkt sie dann wie wir später
sehen wir die angst die sympathisch
antipathien die antipathie sympathie
digital sagen wird das ist etwas was in
der stimmung sich so nicht zeigt also
ist eine weitere these um emotionen noch
klarer von abstimmungen und dosen gefühl
abheben zu können ja jetzt kommen wir zu
der sind leitfragen der heutigen sitzung
also wie fern handelt es sich bei der
verzweiflung um eine emotion
inwiefern besitzt die verzweiflung einen
kognitiven eine gefühlsmäßige und eine
motivation dimension wie manifestiert
sich verzweiflung phänomenal wie verhält
sich die verzweiflung zu den bisher
behandelten emotionen das sind so die
vier fragen die wir uns heute stellen
wollen
und jetzt kommen wir also zum heutigen
denker über die verzweifelte sprechen
nämlich geht es um suhl gekommen der ein
werk geschrieben hat mit dem titel die
krankheit zum tode wie sie bestimmt
gemerkt haben ist dieses werk zumindest
der anfang von dem sie ein text kostet
kommen haben den ich auch unten einem
youtube video verlinkt nicht leicht zu
verstehen
er ist ziemlich dicht und man kann das
ganze semester damit verbringen allein
dieses einleitende kapitel zu
interpretieren wir machen nur in einer
sitzung weil wir uns natürlich nur auf
einen aspekt konzentrieren nämlich auf
die frage inwiefern die verzweiflung
eine emotion ist nach dem was wir bisher
über emotionen kennt gehört haben so
also sagte ich zitiere mal die
verzweiflung ist eine krankheit in geist
und kann so und dreifach sein erstens
dass man der verzweiflung sich nicht
bewusst ist ein selbst zu haben dass die
uhren eigentliche verzweiflung
zweitens dass man verzweifelt nicht man
selbst sein mit und drittens dass man
verzweifelt man selbst zeit will
wir sehen jetzt diese zahlen habe ich
eingefügt das zeigt aber dass es hier
eine steigerung gibt also es gibt
verschiedene formen von verzweiflung und
die nehmen wie auch die zahlen hier an
schärfe zu also die nummer drei dann
verzweifelt man selbst zerrbild das ist
die schlimmste oder gravierendste form
der verzweiflung nach ständiger so und
jetzt hat er ja ganz bekanntes zitat ich
das vor der mensch ist geist was aber
ist geist geist das selbst was das
selbst dass selbst ein verhältnis das
sich zu sich selbst verhält oder ist das
im verhältnis das sich das verhältnis zu
sich selbst verhält dass selbst ist
nicht das verhältnis sondern dass sich
das verhältnis zu sich selbst wenn der
mensch ist eine synthese unendlichkeit
glichkeit vom zeitlichen und ewigen von
freiheit und notwendigkeit kurz eine
synthese eines wts ist ein verhältnis
zwischen 2 so betrachtet ist der mensch
noch kein selbst okay jetzt habe ich
eine grafik also kriegsgegner opposition
unendlichkeit endlichkeit ewigkeit
zeitlichkeit freiheit notwendigkeit und
jetzt gibt es ja eine relation
dazwischen
das ist also diese grundstruktur das ist
diese these halte die das verhältnis
oder auch vielleicht die einheit
zwischen diesen polen und die gegensätze
natürlich kann man sich sagen inwiefern
ist der mensch ist das wäre gut
irgendwie kann man schon sagen der
mensch ist endlich hat wir sterben alle
irgendwann aber irgendwie wir haben ein
begriff unendlichen wir haben irgendwas
was diese ähnlichkeit transzendiert wir
wünschen uns die ähnlichkeit zu
transzendieren gedehnten jedenfalls über
die ehrlichkeit hinaus und darin könnte
man auch eine frau von möglichkeit sehen
genauso die freiheit wir verstehen uns
als frei auf der anderen seite müssen
wir uns unter naturwissenschaftlichen
gesichtspunkten als notwendig
determinieren betracht also irgendwie
sind diese beiden anteil uns zumindest
so ist auch die landläufige
anthropologische bestimmung des menschen
und seine clique gehört darin ist aber
jetzt noch nicht dass selbst gelegen
dass es nur so die grundstruktur
es geht weiter in dem verhältnis
zwischen zwei ist als negative einheit
das verhältnis das dritte und die zwei
verhalten sich zum verhältnis und im
verhältnis zum verhältnis unter den
bestimmungsort verhältnis zwischen ziele
und lang ein verhältnis verhält sich
dagegen das verhältnis zu sich selbst so
ist dieses verhältnis das positive
dritte und dies ist das selbst okay also
in dem verhältnis zu zwei was wir jetzt
vor einsam ist das verhältnis als dieser
pfeil dazwischen endlichkeit
die ewigkeit freude tourismus das dritte
aber eben nur das negative dritte und
das positive dritten ist wenn sich das
verhältnis noch mal zu sich selbst
verhält
das ist dass selbst okay also wir hatten
gesehen dass ist jetzt das negative
dritte also 12 negatives drittes und das
kann das positive dritte es bezieht sich
noch mal auf sich selbst also das ist
jetzt das selbst könnte sagen die
grundstruktur des menschen und die wird
noch mal im menschen selbst reflektiert
dieses selbst reflektiven reflexive das
ist durch diesen dritten fall dass
positive dritte ausgedrückt okay es geht
wartet ein solches feld bis dass ich zu
dir selbst erhält ein selbst muss ihren
wieder selbst gesetzt haben oder durch
ein anderes gesetz zeigt ist das
verhältnis dass ich zu sich selbst fällt
durch ein anderes gesetz so ist das
verhältnis freilich das dritte aber
dieses verhältnis das dritte ist so doch
wieder ein verhältnis und verhält sich
zu dem was das ganze verhältnis gesetzt
hat also jetzt gibt es zwei optionen
dieses verhältnis wird sich selbst
verhält kann er sich selbst gesetzt
haben oder von etwas anderem gesetzt
sein
wir menschen würde zum beispiel kirkuk
aussagen die meisten wir uns auch sagen
wir haben uns nicht gesetzt sondern wir
wurden gesetzt die frage ist nur von wem
oder was wurden wie gesetzt also damit
ist jetzt nicht zu ende die ganze
relationale konstellation des selbst
denkt das in relation zu müssen nochmal
eine relation drauf bauen aufstocken so
zu sagen und die verhält nicht zum
selbst hat es etwas anderen der kümmern
es ein großes fragezeichen immer die
naturwissenschaft zeit deflation hat uns
gesetzt
die theologen theologin sagen gott hat
uns gesetzt ich glaube dass auch
jedenfalls möchte es nur ganz normal so
bestimmt dass eben doch mal ein
zusätzlicher relation dazu kommt ein
solches abgeleitetes gesetz des
verhältnis ist dass selbst das menschen
ein verhältnis da sich zu sich selbst
verhält und sich in diesem zu sich
selbst verhalten zu einem anderen
verhält
daher kommt es dass es zwei formen
eigentlicher verzweiflung gehen kann
hätte das selbst des menschen sich
selbst gesetzt so könnten wurde von
einer form die rede sein von der nicht
man selbst zu sein sich selbstlos ein zu
freuen
aber es könne nicht davon die rede sein
von zwei wie man selbst sein zu bauen
diese formel ist nämlich der ausdruck
für die abhängigkeit des ganzen
verhältnis der selbst der ausdruck dafür
dass das selbst nicht durch sich selbst
zum gleichgewicht oder zur ruhe kommen
oder darin sein kann so nur so dass es
sich im verhalten ist jetzt zu dem tier
helfen dass das ganze verhältnis gesetzt
okay das ist also dieses konstrukt uhr
das 1 2 ford gibt und das hat die
eigentliche folgen verzweifeln besteht
darin verzweifelt man selbst sein zu
wollen und die stellen sich ihnen dann
umso dringlicher
wenn man sich nicht gesetzt hat zudem
das andere gesetzt wurde
ja ich will es auch nicht allzu lange um
den heißen brei herumreden wir wollen
jetzt gleich konkret auf die für zweifel
kommen jetzt sagt er wird nach folgendes
zu wenig bezeichnet diese zweite form
der verzweiflung nämlich verzweifelt man
selbst sein zu wollen
so ist eine besondere art von
verzweiflung das im gegenteil zuletzt
alle vertrauen in sie auflösen und auf
sie zurückführen lässt wenn eine
verzweifelte wie er meint auf seine
verzweifelten aufmerksam ist nicht
sinnlos davon als von etwas redet weil
sie begegnet und nun daran macht durch
sich selbst und allein durch sich selbst
die vorgeben will dann ist dennoch in
der verzweiflung und arbeitet sich mit
allem seinen vermeintlichen arbeiten um
so tiefer in eine tiefe von 1 also wir
kommen nach kicker gar nichts einfach
aus dieser verzweifelten auch jetzt noch
genannt noch gar nicht genau bestimmt
hat was eigentlich die verzweiflung ist
und jetzt kommen wir der sache mehr also
es geht um ein missverhältnis und das
ist das verzweifeln
also ein missverhältnis in diesen
verschiedenen relationen die ich vorhin
als schlimmer gebracht hat und
interessanterweise kommt titel war
gleich am anfang auf
die endzustand zu sprechen also den
zustand wo wir nicht mehr verzweifelt
sind sagte im verhalten zu sich selbst
und in dem es selbst sein will gründen
sich da selbst durchsichtig aufgemacht
die es jetzt also um der verzweiflung zu
entgehen und der wir immer bedroht sind
müssen wir nach clicker uns klar darüber
werden von wem war's wir gesetzt sind
uns darin gründen was auch immer jetzt
gründen bedeutet also müssen im grunde
genommen die ganze komplexe relationale
verfasstheit unserer selbst die müssen
wir ganz ganz klar durchschauen die muss
jetzt völlig transparent geworden sein
ja jetzt stellt sich die frage ist
verzweifelt meinen 40 oder einfach mal
rein elektrisch sagte kreis sie beides
wenn man den abstrakt gedanken von zwei
form festhalten wollte ohne an einen
verzweifeln zu denken so müsste man
sagen sie ist ein ungeheurer vorzug
die möglichkeit dieser krankheit ist es
menschen vorzuführen tiere und dieser
vorzug zeichnet ihn ganz anders aus als
der aufrichtigen denn er deutet auf die
unendliche aufgerichtet hat wir haben
halt hin das denken ganz fest dazu muss
ich jetzt mal folgendes sagen wenn wir
im alltag über verzweiflung sprechen
dann denken wir sicherlich nicht an so
nicht verzweifeln wie kicker das ist
ganz ähnlich wie mit dem ekel wenn wir
im alltag einen ekel denken dann denken
wir ein würgereflex reine ekelhaftes
objekt genau so denken wir haben wenn
wir an die verzweiflung länger eine
hoffnungslose situation eine
ausweglosigkeit an eine situation in der
wir nicht weder ein noch aus wissen wo
wir vielleicht auch in panik geraten das
ist so die alltägliche bedeutung von
verzeiht vom kicker wie audrey lädt die
verzweiflung metaphysisch auf und er
sieht er im netzgebiet eine
grundstruktur des verhältnis des
menschen zur welt ist also eine viel
komplexere relation und nicht nur
irgendein gefühl ja also es ist ein
vorzug aber eben auch ein nachteil wenn
sie etwas ganz besonderes ich komm noch
auf ein zitat zu sprechen bezweifeln ist
das missverhältnis in dem verhältnis
einer synthese dass ich zu sich selbst
verhält als ein missverhältnis hier
stimmt was in diesen ganzen relationen
nicht
und jetzt kommt gott ins spiel also es
ist ein missverhältnis dass sie uns
nicht transparent zu diesem grund der
uns gesetzt haben
tat und täter beschreibt es die
verzweiflung so dass sie eine qual ist
er sprach von einer krankheit würden im
alltag nicht davon sprechen dass
verzweiflung eine krankheit bei
depressionen würden wir vielleicht davon
sprechen verzweiflung er nicht und er
sagt es ist eine qual dass man nicht
sterben kann also deswegen heißt sie
auch das buch die krankheit zu tode
sie hat so mehr mit dem zustand des tod
kann gemein wenn ihr da liegt und sich
mit dem tode plaques und nicht sterben
kann so heißt zum tode kranksein nicht
sterben können jedoch nicht als ob das
lebens hoffnung wäre nein
die hoffnungslosigkeit ist die er selbst
die letzte hoffnung der tod nicht kommt
die größte gefahr ist so hofft man auf
leben wenn man aber die noch
schrecklichere gefahr kennen lernt hofft
man auf den tod wenn also die gefahr so
groß ist dass der tod zum gegenstand der
hoffnung geworden ist dann ist
verzweifelt die hoffnungslosigkeit nicht
einmal sterben zu können also das geht
so weiter und sagt selbst der tod ist
keine erlösung kein ausweg aus dem der
verzweiflung sondern die verzweiflung
besteht eben darin dass man nicht
sterben kann was ein permanentes sagen
sterben also was eben nicht beendet wird
das ist eine sehr drastische schilderung
dann würden wir sicherlich im alltag
sagen wir diskutieren nachher etwas
näher über das ist nicht mein begriff
und verzweiflung ging ich habe dieser
letzten bedeutung ist man verzweifeln
die krankheit zu tode dieser qualvollen
wieder spuckt diese krankheit in selbst
ewig zu sterben zu stellen und doch
nicht zu sterben des todes zu sterben
entsperrten bedeutet dass es vorbei ist
aber das todes sterben bedeutet dass man
das sterben erlebt und lässt sich dieses
einzigen augenblick erlebens erlebt man
es damit für ewig würde der menschen in
verzweiflung sterben wie man eine
krankheit stirbt dann müsste das ewige
ihm das selbst im selben sinne sterben
können wieder andere krankheit stirbt
also die these von kicker ist und das
muss man jetzt wirklich ganz ernst
nehmen wir sterben eben nach klick kann
sofern die ein selbst sind nicht so wie
wir als organismus stehe in einem
organismus stört an einer krankheit
anschluss aber dass selbst fasst rüdiger
eben von diesem organismus von diesem
bloßen naturalistischen äußeren nur
unterschieden werden muss dass stirbt
trieben auf eine ganz besondere weise
und ist eben deswegen auch verzweifelt
das ist eine sehr merkwürdige
charakterisierung die man sie noch
genauer anschauen muss ein verzweifelter
verzweifelt über etwas so sieht ist ein
augenblick aus aber nur einen augenblick
im selben augenblick zeigt sich die
wahre verzweiflung oder die verzweiflung
ihrer wahrheit in dem er über etwas
verzeichnete verzweifelt er eigentlich
über sich selbst und will sich nun
selbst loswerden denn so der
herrschsüchtige des losung heisst
entweder zwei oder gar nichts nicht
besser wird so verzweifelt erhalten
das bedeutet aber etwas anderes dass er
eben weil er nicht sicher wurde ist nun
nicht aushalten kann er selbst zu sein
alles so verzweifelt er eigentlich nicht
darüber dass er sowohl sollten bei sich
selbst dass er nichts er wurde als das
trifft jetzt eine interessante frage die
auch ziemlich konkret ist was
verzweifeln wir eigentlich da zweifeln
ist ja immer ein mehrstündiges prädikat
also die person iks wird zweifeln über y
und die these von trainer ist das objekt
des verzweifelt ist eine die person
selbst auch wenn sie es nicht genau weiß
ja der verzweifelte ist todkrank in eine
ganz andere weise als man es sonst von
einer krankheit sagen kann hat die
krankheit derzeit edelsten teile
angegriffen und doch kann er
der 4 2 für den ead sterben der tod ist
nicht das letzte der krankheit sondern
der tod ist fortwährend das letzte von
dieser krankheit durch den tod gerettet
zu werden ist eine unmöglichkeit denn
die krankheit und ihre qual und der ton
ist gerade dass man nicht sterben kann
ja das ist natürlich eine sehr sehr
starke these über die wir jetzt genau
das kritisieren wollen die geheimnisse
und aus bis zur nächsten sitzung da geht
es knallhart weiter die angst und zwar
bald ihr gegangen heutige und ich
verabschiede mich zumindest jetzt auf
youtube und freue mich bis auf die
nächste sitzung